alright shall we begin
good morning good morning everyone this
is Jack Van Horn from the bd2k training
coordinating center based at the
University of Southern California and
I'd like to welcome you all to our next
installment of our bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science seminar
series this morning we're absolutely
delighted to have a Pascal Cotte egg
from the Swiss Institute of
bioinformatics who will be lecturing on
data curation and version control dr
g'day has been working as a bio curator
since 2003 first with the model organism
database dicta base at Northwestern
University in Chicago during which time
she became heavily involved in the gene
ontology project since October of 2010
dr. g'day has been the scientific
manager of the next database at the
Swiss Institute of bioinformatics which
is based in Switzerland she is founding
one of the founding members of the
International Society for bio curators
and has served as its chairperson from
2009 to 2013 this morning she's going to
be again talking about data curation and
version control and she will attempt to
explain what a bio curat or is what bio
curation is and what is the process by
which the life site lifecycle of
scientific data goes through and discuss
relevant issues for all of you who are
listening I encourage you to chat in
using the little chat box feature of
your questions and we will I will axe to
kind of curate them myself and ask them
on your behalf
without further ado dr. good day welcome
and thank you very much thank you
introduction thank you for inviting me
to give this lecture I'm really you see
my screen okay yes we can okay so just
to say it's a big honor for me to be
part of this course and I'm very pleased
of their recognition by bd2k of the
importance of bio curation in data
science and biomedical
so this is to summarize with jacta said
about me
so I'm their scientific manager of next
prod at the assistant suit of my
informatics I'm also still currently a
manager on the gene ontology project is
this specifically on the phylogenetic
annotation approach project and here I I
copied what some other previous
presenters did and I gave the people my
email and my Twitter account in case you
want to continue discussing but I'm
going to be talking about today after
this talk so databases right now are a
cornerstone stone for research curated
databases are tool that most we right
now on a day and and many users spend
several hours per week on on various
databases when I was a dicta base we we
surveyed our users and many people
estimated that they were spending
probably one day a week overall on
various resources however database
creation and maintenance is an obscure
process to most users sorry I just I
just need to yeah so that'll base
creation and maintenance is an obscure
process to most user and this is what I
want to talk about to you today so I'm
sure everybody here has interacted with
many of these different types of
resources but this is to give you an
idea for to remind you of the scope of
curated resources in the life sciences
so there's databases that talk about
protein functions genomes chemicals
clinical trials interactions with
ligands with drugs with proteins there's
a large number of databases in
the the main reference in terms of
article databases is the yearly nucleic
acids research database which in 2016
listed one thousand six hundred and
sixty five different databases and
there's the link here for the list of
databases that are compiled by the
Michael galperin who's the editor for
the nucleic acids research database
issue I want to point out that this is
not an exhaustive list of all the
databases that exist the any our
database issues selects resources that
are deemed of high quality that are non
redundant with other existing resources
so in other words if you want to propose
a repackaging of other databases it's
usually not going to make it in the
collection of databases and also the
Select resources that are maintained and
so just to say there is a large number
of what we call niche databases usually
created for specific projects but that
are not maintained wants for example the
students are closed out moves on to a
different projects so these are excluded
from the nucleic acids research
Saturday's issue and and even within
this collection there's still a small
number that goes absolute every year and
so just as a point to mention this year
there were 23 resources that were
removed because they didn't seem to be
maintained anymore so today I'm going to
talk about what is bio curation why do
bio curation and how do we do bio
curation so to give a definition of bio
curation we can say that it's the
analysis interpretation and integration
of biological information into data
repositories so it's in part data
capture but that's really just one
aspect to do by a curation you need
understand the data you need to analyze
it and you need to distill what the
researchers are trying to show in order
to translate this into a language that a
computer will be able to understand and
this is a little subtlety without
falling into the trap of over
interpreting data when for example
interesting new theories are discussed
in papers but there's not the exact
supporting evidence that one needs to
really say that this is a an observation
that's been shown whereas this is a
conclusion that we might want to test in
the future so this data is integrated
into some structured form usually it's a
database but it doesn't really have to
be this is very technical I'm not going
to focus on the technical aspects and so
really by a curation and conferences a
wide range of a wide range of activities
so this definition may not include all
the different activities but to give you
an idea of the some of the typical tasks
that a bio curator might do it's to
conceptualize well certain types of data
to create databases to evaluate data
insert it in the database and also if
possible link it so that it makes sense
biologically and and obviously start so
why can you buy a curation I mean right
now as we know modern research generates
huge quantities of data and while each
data set is very rich or each data point
even is very rich on its own where it
becomes powerful and interesting is when
we can in the different data from
different groups from different types of
experiments and so on and so one aim of
bio curation and curated databases is to
be able to connect and query all the
knowledge that we have generated as a
scientific community I mean I think this
is anyways a common goal of
the entire scientific community so why
buy your creation is also because papers
in the traditional form are not easily
amenable to computational analysis so
the data that is there the knowledge
that is there is very difficult to
extract so it's usually that when there
was a little less literature accumulated
people could be expert and have read
everything in their field but more and
more this is becoming almost impossible
another thing is that biological data is
very heterogeneous so there is many
different techniques that ask similar
questions new techniques are
constructively being developed so one of
the challenges is also systems where all
this data can be a little bit more and
terrible a parable and so this is not
exactly built in into how people
currently do experiments so right now
we're at it as stage where the infant
the the data and the knowledge generated
by experiments cannot be immediately
consumed for other types of analyses
so they right now the process is to
convert this into a form that can be
computed so the idea with bio curation
is that if we have data that is
correctly captured then we can
facilitate retrieval extraction
indexation and make the data as a whole
more valuable so what we're hoping for
that a curated knowledge database will
provide is easy access to data data that
is sun repeating this a little bit
better this is a really the very
important in terms of why we're doing
state this well
also and ideally did the other thing is
it enables burnout and just a point on
the occurrence sometimes if you and you
haven't read other articles that have
been published afterwards you don't know
if that what was demonstrated in that
article is still the best of you're
looking at so ideally we would have a
way you know databases aimed to provide
the current state of knowledge so there
that has been shown to be incorrect or
inaccurate should be removed corrected
okay so how do we do bio curation there
is really the the first one is manual
and the other one is automated or
assisted with text mining
I'm going to describe both approaches
but first I'm gonna focus on on the
manual approach so some of the four oh
yeah so I just want to say that I for
today stock I give some examples of
literature curation of these types of
there's many types of data that are
curated there's many type of databases I
can mentioned earlier so for the
examples today I'm going to focus on
literature curation just for simplicity
I unfortunately there is no time to go
over all the different types of curation
that can be done but one that comes to
mind really very important thing that I
won't be talking about this genome
annotation gene models sequence features
and so on so here's an overview of what
a curator does as specific steps when
annotating a paper from the literature
so first you need what I call bio
entities Pro
the paper because usually what people
want to do is to connect it verification
or a phenotype so you need to know what
gene is being described enough it seem
trivial to two people doing research and
writing papers but when you're on the
other end reading papers and trying to
extract listen for me in fact it's an
extremely challenging task as there's
trivia for example when a gene name is
synonym is the sin of another gene so
sometimes you need to a paper is talking
about issues of these that can be people
describe variants or even post
translational modification
aminoacylation on the current reference
sequence is different from the one that
was presented in the paper it's also to
be resolved and also it can be difficult
to find the species that is described in
a paper
there's several cases that we have
encountered where a paper talks about a
human process but somehow when you read
in very much detail their materials and
methods or sometimes even it has
happened that we had to do a blast and
then we realized that in fact it was a
mouthful thing being expressed in the
human cell okay so we just always want
to make sure that whatever information
is extracted from the paper is linked to
the correct biological entity so this is
the first thing if - I just extract
which gene the paper or genes the paper
is talking about also obviously you want
to extract whatever real information
knowledge is published in the paper so
for example they show a molecular
function or they show
pathway in which the gene is involved in
SS for elation site the phenotype and so
on and synthesize the information to
represent like I said their current
state of knowledge so you it also
happens that the tears at the level of
data presentation are some examples of
by entity recognition issues so maybe if
some of you are familiar with a PC which
represents either the protein involved
in colon cancer or the NFA is promoting
complex so people familiar with that
literature would immediately know that
these are different kinds of papers but
there's not trivial for everybody to
recognize there is also here i am i put
some drosophila genes but there's a it's
not that it's the only case where
there's genes that are named with warts
that are real English words and so
obviously this can also cause the false
negative problems you're looking for the
literature for that gene and and you
find a lot of papers that talk about
white but it's very difficult to find
the papers that talk about the gene
white and I mentioned in the previous
slide that the sequence I the form
species issues but this is a something
that curators spend a long time trying
to sort out when annotating a paper so
to discuss a little bit the second step
of the by a curation task patient and
I'm gonna give you an example of a work
that we've done in my group and so we've
curated the functional impact of
variations in the human genome for a
number of cancer variants and so you are
interested in really capturing the
molecular mechanism of these variants so
we can
and internet seller processes it's in
molecular binding changes in pro or in
subcellular localization and this is the
this is the overview of the end I'm sure
many of you have seen these types of
databases where you can go and browse
some information though you there
phenotypes of the gene mlh1 involved in
colorectal cancer and at the first level
we show the different phenotypes that
are tested for this gene
so there is I cannot get my mouse to
work here but we have divided them by
groups so the clear function so the
molecular function ATPase activity there
is also impact on biological process of
the OS not repair its localization which
is nuclear and impact on some important
binary interactions and you can go in
and search for any gene that has a
defect in a specific phenotype you are
interested in so for example you can
look at the list of variants that have
defects in this not repair and so here
there's the four different variants
listed so this is a partial or 100
different variants for this gene with
problems in this not repair and so we
also show all the evidence for the data
that we're capturing so this is I think
very important in terms of trusting the
data
anybody who downloads does this NIST can
then go back to the original literature
and decide if you agree with the
information which is presented there
so so this was the end result so going
back on how we actually extract the
information so this is one of their
articles that we used to annotate mlh1
and so one of the challenge
Jim is dispersed in this case it's
there's information dispersed within the
same table but sometimes it's even more
widespread in the paper so we have the
gene name MLA twelve of the title of the
table a list of mutation in the table we
also have the phenotypes in which we're
interested in that I highlighted in
yellow so there
ms:i status it stands for microsatellite
instability status so this is something
that tumors in it measures essentially
whether or not the mismatch repair
system is functional or not and in this
case it's it's given a qualitative value
high-low or not tested and then the
other column we were interested in
capturing like I mentioned is the
protein stability and so in this case
it's tested by in your chemistry in your
cycle chemistry so we know this because
we know that in this case amino psycho
chemistry measures the level of the
protein in the cell but obviously you
can do a minnow cycle chemistry to
measure many other things just the
localization and so on
also there is in this table a number of
variants that are not original from this
paper that is so for some reason they
thought these are interesting and the
add of them their authors added them in
their analysis but they're the the data
wasn't and so in these cases we we don't
nation
just cited because we walk we only
capture each experiment only once
is it cited in the secondary publication
we we don't capture it so this because
otherwise it would give artificial
weight to the assertion because it's
been found X number of times so I think
it's very important that anytime
something has been shown that T that
doesn't get duplicated in the annotation
process this is a similar data a
different paper so in this case they
also tell des Eaux histo chemistry as
you see on the left and they tested in
what they call step to mmrsa which is
also testing mismatch repair is very
similar data is just presented in a very
different way oh so the legend says that
the black cells represent data genic are
deficient me H cells are non-pathogenic
the diagonal line means that it hasn't
been tested and the gray cells mean that
there is conflicting data so this is
something that manually we can
understand but that automatic annotation
systems I don't I don't know of any
system that can extract the information
from such a table now this paper that
you find quite frequently in research
papers is a small case a small case F
next to the variant PK 61 and 618
alanine so in the legend it says that
these families have additional mutations
so in this case there's two mutations in
the same gene and so of course footnote
may be very important in terms of the
the explanation of the phenotype so in
this case we're looking at a double
mutant but in that table it's presented
that as a single mutant so again this is
some of the very detailed work that our
team and many other team does to make
sure that we extract all the information
accurately now I mentioned that there's
a microsatellite instability and the
second paper had MMR which is a mismatch
repair as assay there's different types
of experiments that test the same thing
in this in this mismatch repair field so
in this case I listed four different
experiments microsatellite instability
in vitro mismatch repair assay mutaters
phenotype as image these are say all
reflect effective mismatch repair
pathway so we believe that it's very
important that these be captured in the
same manner or there is four different
to explain a little bit more about the
work on gene ontology and I think many
of you must be familiar with the gene
ontology it's one of the most widely
used bioinformatics resource it's a
shared language for the annotation of
molecular
functions and biological process and
seller components across different
organisms and it covers three different
domains like I just said function
process component and develop this is
exactly to be able to standardize the
description of gene function like I just
said by a curators link gene our gene
products are modified proteins and so on
two times of the gene ontology or
various anthologies in order for the
data to be organized in a consistent way
and for users to be able to to consume
it in a way that is so in terms of the
mlh1 protein for example that i was
mentioning its function is to bind
another complex it's involved in this
mat repair and it's localized to the
nucleus okay so and it has a number of
other more subtle you know gene ontology
functions annotations gene ontology
annotations to function or process and
component but these are their most
central ones so I suppose that you might
be familiar with other biomedical
ontologies there's right now bio medical
oncology in in most areas so to describe
and atthenes can chemicals diseases
experiments so the mass spectrometry
community has an anthology that
describes the different techniques that
they use
there's also yeah in the gold chain
describe protein function and subsolar
component can describe phenotypes can
describe proteins and protein families
sequence and so on so this is really one
way to represent the data that also has
been proven that research community if
we just look at how much the gene
ontology is being used in bioinformatics
applications
so one comment that we often get about
bio curation manual buyer curation is
that it's it it's long and it doesn't
scale easily although it's very accurate
we need to develop ways to make manual
annotation so I'm gonna give you one
example in that direction in the gene
ontology consortium we have developed a
tool called paint phylogenetic based
annotation and France and what you do is
we make gene ontology annotations
relations I'm just going to spend a
couple of sites describing this here
what we have in on the left is a gene
family for msh2
which is another member of the mismatch
repair complex
so there's proteins this is conserved
from human to e.coli and so there if the
the sequences in grain experiment made
by other group and you can do using this
as we look at the ships of all these
genes and then we can decide where a
function first evolved and then we what
we call propagate or infer that function
to the anode a phylogenetic ancestor
that we choose and is the second step of
the annotation where from this ancestor
the annotations are propagated to the
ones in blue the ones that didn't have
any annotations okay so the workflow is
to look at the experimental annotations
shown here in blue and look so
essentially that the processes we look
for the most recent common ancestor and
then we decide if
one annotate to the or if we think that
it should be annotated to a more recent
ancestor or more ancient ancestor and so
then for me these decisions include for
example sequence conservation active
site presence or absence and a number of
other things and so I don't know if you
can see this alignment probably but we
can also annotate a function so it
happens in big multi gene families that
certain functions are lost in this case
it's because an active site is lost so
the sistine the of PGM v but in the PGM
one clade the cysteine is mutated to an
Apsara gene and therefore the function
is not after this duplication event
indicated in the green circle and so
using this also say you know that there
has been a loss of function and so this
is to give you some idea of how much
more we can do using this more efficient
curated curation system so as of last
year we had 2,500 different families
curated so the families are based on
thank our DB right now there is a
families in the in the whole panther TV
set so we've done about a quarter and
within those 2500 families there has
been over five thousand human genes
annotated and 20,000 new human gene
annotations and if you look at also all
the organisms we have nearly 1 million
annotations with the system this scales
quite well in the sense that one curator
can do about one family 1000 families a
year which if you take the average that
corresponds Lauren as to 100
and genes so the only drawback is that
of course we still need the primary
annotations in order to be able to do
this but the nice thing is it annotates
multiple new in no annotations so now
I'm gonna switch gears a little bit talk
about automated curation so the manual
curation is very nice but like I said
it's it's time-consuming and there's a
lot of hope that some automated systems
could help us do curation more
effectively so the the tasks that
automated curation tools that I'm aware
of do include document retrieval
document prioritization what they call
right so let's say if you're interested
in a specific gene a special specific
disease it can retrieve documents that
are relevant to that gene disease
process it can that the these tools
these document which ones are more
likely to be more interesting to you
gene normalization task is to try to
identify which gene the paper is talking
about so this task as far as I know
maybe there's been more recent
developments where this as I explained
earlier in my talk even manually we have
a lot of issues so the automatic systems
were not usually performing really well
in this task and finally another task is
concept identification so which gene is
mentioned in the paper are dis mentioned
in the paper and so on so these are all
tasks that we can ask automated systems
to help us with one very popular tool in
the bio curation community for automatic
annotation is called expresso
it's developed by the group or who also
is gif they're warm based database and
so it was first implemented in one base
but it's now and more and more
frequently being implemented in other
data invicta days and ter there are with
our adopts italiana resource so what the
expresso can do is if it's given on the
Left a number of PDFs of relevant
literature gene product names and
synonym that it can use as a search base
and while for ter and some plan seller
component funds so essentially you have
your your literature and your list of
genes and just it in what the expresso
does is it converts the PDF to text it
tries to identify the changing product
names it marks up the text of the type
or it indexes it and then it presents it
to the curator in a ways I'm just going
to show you this is from the 2012 papers
that describe implementation of the
expresso indict abates and in and so
this is a the curation the curation
interface so at the top is the the title
and abstract of the paper and then at
the bottom you see the gene protein name
that the system extracted a gene
ontology cellular component or nuclear
that it found in this then you can also
select more specific or less specific
term and then the curator just sees this
pre-processed annotation and can hit
make the curation make the annotation or
don't make the annotation and this goes
directly in the database now in
automatic annotation the gold standard
measures are
Precision's and recall our the fraction
of their documents retrieved that are
relevant to your query okay so how how
much of your corpus did you really find
and the precision is the fraction of the
documents that are retrieved and that
are relevant which is the system
obviously can also give you some false
positives right so there recall is it
measures more or less they're they're
false negatives first they're false
positives and so this is again from the
paper so for dictation tear the recall
was Maxima and so they're still 50% of
the literature that the curators needed
to go back to and annotate manually and
the precision was yeah between sixty and
seventy five percent so sometimes there
were a number of false positives too but
despite that here I call this a class
reduction that's not how they phrased it
in the paper but in the paper they say a
2.5 fold increase in curation efficiency
so it's so pretty good you can annotate
more than two times the number of papers
that you would without this system the
cons here I would say that usually these
things don't take in the cost don't take
in development ignorance of the
infrastructure that you need behind and
also there's birch projects in this area
that to a real life setting okay so it's
right now it's still pretty embryonic
and there's lots of research going on
but in able to use automated methods for
by a curation there there's a lot of
tasks that cannot be done
okay so we talked about what why how and
now I would like to talk about who the
Spyder curation so as Jack mentioned
before bio curation is done by
professional by curators such as me so
we surveyed there by curators back in
2012 and there's a paper that described
who are these people and where they come
from and why they became interested in
in this area but just to say that most
people have a lot of experience most are
PhD most have a lot of experience as
bench scientists so most and also
postdocs and some people have done some
programming and usually people stay in
bio creation for a long time so people
are experienced researchers and
experienced curators also it was
mentioned that the by curators have a
professional society called the Anton
fighty for bio curation and different
numbers that represents about the
hundred fifty different institution
there is a annual international meetings
that are very interesting in terms of
giving people new ideas and new ways to
do things and to collaborate so I think
these are really really good for the
community and it's amazing that next
year is already going to be the tenth
annual meeting of the International
Society for bio curation so this is a
bit restating what I said at the
beginning in terms of the importance of
curated resources that's with the from
the point of view of the by curators
themselves so what we would like to have
is to have compatible infrastructure for
detailed position exchange and analysis
so it's important that we have can come
and control the cab Aries compatible
tools compatible identifier
data formats in systems and so on at the
same time it's island stability and
innovation we don't want to be in a
situation where nerds are so rigid that
people cannot start doing new types of
experiments so this is also very
challenging to be back compatible move
forward at the same time we would like
for the resources that were developing
to be sustainable and I came to get
researchers involved so that's one
aspect of their one group of people who
do bio curation there's other approaches
than you so one day so the crowdsourcing
can be divided into three different
aspects one is a thing scientist to
contribute theory there's a wiki James I
know back 7 10 years ago most of them
other organism databases and cemented
their own wiki to try to get researchers
to add their own data if they wanted our
fam is one their best example of a very
City the second approach in
crowdsourcing is much but people might
know as and as on parks so you can go to
the to Amazon and propose I mean that
formal but you propose a very small task
and people ours are paid a small amount
to do one unit Apple to identify
variants in an abstract so just to tell
you is this string of text
a variant yes or no paper that the net
Harshman published about this it was it
was
quite successful for that small task but
then of course if you want to do more
complicated tasks then you need to start
making bigger payments and you also want
you control for the contributors their
expertise how many false positives they
give you and so on like with the quality
of their work there is also an
interesting idea in in developing games
that could help somehow
integrate data in a more structured way
so there's a there's well folded is not
exactly going in databases but for
protein predictions with the most
successful game in biology where people
biologists and other people could try to
find the best structure for a protein of
the whose structure was not known there
is also Cancer Research UK who developed
a few games and while other groups and
rousu among other people I don't know
why I forgot to fit his name there but
so there's a few ideas of getting people
involved in a fun way but there hasn't
been picked up it's not like everybody's
playing these by informatics game while
they're waiting for the bus or something
at least not as far as I know so the
pros of crowdsourcing are enough
potential contributors there's there's a
significant cost to developing all this
infrastructure and many of them if
they're not used very much well it
becomes a money that was invested for
not much return and and mostly at least
their reports I have looked at describe
pretty low rates of participation so
that's too bad really because it would
be really great group which is very
important for bio curation as a whole is
researcher many research projects
involves some cure
and that data is now always contributed
back to databases or often it's not
there are some journals that encourage
researchers to provide data and format
that can be directly inserted in
databases so for example gene ontology
annotations if you Journal request that
but clearly the incentives are not yet
there for people to to really provide a
lot of data researchers have a lot of
other it's not not much recognition for
having provided your data or not so we
really need to work on providing better
incentives for researchers to curate
their own data and and I mean one
obvious way that I can think is and
that's that's discussed a lot lately
it's not my idea is to give some either
via your arkad your Ark ID or some other
mechanism that curated data would
receive some sizable unit ok so that the
last little bit of the talk I'm going to
discuss versioning issues so because all
these curated databases are available
out there there's more and more
experiments that rely on these resources
for data analysis especially in the high
throughput area however most papers that
I read that do by informatics analysis
do not provide enough data to reproduce
their experiment their data analysis
experiment here so that's one issue this
is slightly different issue is I
mentioned that I you created resources
want to be up to date with respect
the current knowledge so this is an
example of a case where we have a
protein that is a dimer and when the a
subunit is down to the D subunit the a
subunit inhibit the activity of the B
now there is a protease that comes in
and that degrades the a subunit and the
b subunit becomes active okay so this is
a not a very complicated mechanism of
regulation so the a subunit is involved
in regulation the b subunit has it's a
it's a nuclease right it has the oxy
ribonuclease activity now the reason why
I'm saying this is that they didn't know
that it was a complex the they had only
identified the the a subunit and they
thought that the a subunit had the
activity so when you read the further a
litter then you realize that the
resolution of the first assays were not
good enough and the results were I guess
he can say wrong but it was just
misleading that the we did the
experiment they didn't have their
resolution to determine whether that
there were two subunits there so the
idea is that to remove this annotation
on the incorrect yeah to move the
incorrect annotation to make sure that
the knowledge is kept up-to-date and
where I want to go with this is this is
just an example like a very specific
example that I want to show you that
annotations evolved annotation evolved
quite a bit in fact so here there is a
tool developed by Paul Pavley this at
the University of British Columbia where
you can query either a gene or a gene
ontology term and see how it changes
over time and in this case I just picked
protein kinase activity and we see four
different species the number of
annotations over time since 2012 2002
anyways only human annotated protein
kinase activity but it's not as one
might expect a linear increase there is
also time where there is a big drop or
big increase and so that means that
depending on when you do your bind from
Attucks experiments using this data your
results can change quite dramatically
and to illustrate this there was a paper
published just a few that shows that
that showed the impact of evaded gene
annotation on pathway enrichment
analysis so for high-throughput
experiment pathway enrichment analysis
is really something that people almost
always present in the paper and what
they've shown here is we looked at a
number of different articles and they
also took visually took annotations from
2010 and 16 and checked from these
different data sets which terms were
most enriched and so the purple dots are
2016 and blue dots are 2000 and as our
yellow that's our 2010 and blue dots are
the ones that are found in both so you
see that there's a number of top between
2016 2010 and now and you also see with
the purple dot that there's many times
that are now enriched that then used to
be enriched if you use their 2010 raw
data so it's very important to to know
which version of the of the tool region
of the data that you're using and so
here is just a few best practices for
bioinformatics experiments should be
people who use curated resources and
associated tools should include
publications
and version number of their tools so the
date of the data set and version number
of their tools and also I find sometimes
in papers people make additional
annotations because the family was
incomplete and so this information these
additional annotations are not always
publicly about so I would just like to
conclude by saying that by curation
should be an integral part of their of
the data lifecycle and so right now it's
often that it the curation occurs post
publication but I'm really hoping that
we can get to a point where the bio
curation will also be part of the data
management plan part of the collection
plan and part of the analysis and that
it won't just be curated after the fact
I'm gonna stop here I took yeah quite a
bit of fun and I would like to thank you
for being here and acknowledge the main
projects I'm involved with
thank you very much Pascal that was
fantastic
which talk we've had a number of
questions we have a couple look at
couple of the themes of the questions
they seem to revolve around quality
control and how automated quality
control and verification they're also
when you're doing a manual curation how
do you decide which studies to include
and is there a panel of experts or some
sort of expert you address some of that
perhaps short so in terms of oh I think
it really depends on the type of data
you're looking at so for example for
sequence information you can certainly
do that by automatically making sure
that the TN you're annotating really
corresponds to a position in the
reference genome for example in terms of
literature curation it's it's very hard
to have
nets that will catch problems but we
certainly have the same papers by for
example christophe decimals group where
they compare the gene ontology
annotations made predicted
electronically and then they compare how
many time how often these were confirmed
by experimental annotations later so
that also helps to to do some what we
call sanity checks but it's true that
the the quality controls are very
important one of the one of the other
questions where are many of the
databases that you mentioned are they
publicly available yeah they should all
be fantastic yeah what one question I
had is you mentioned a little people who
are bio curators and I'm curious what
sort of involvement you see from people
from the library Sciences or almost like
Museum Sciences who've had some
experience with this and are you seeing
some sort of kind of comparisons between
the type of work being done in libraries
and museums with the type of work that's
being done with bio curation yeah it's
funny because I was reading articles
about this recently and my experience
and it's consistent with what I was
reading is it's not sufficient we it's
true the sciences we started to develop
tools and infrastructure and dependently
really with the life sciences in mind
but definitely we can college that
librarian scientists have accumulated
over the years this is also another
direction that this community should
take in my opinion yeah I mean it seems
like and somebody had asked a question
about a fundamental difference between
the archivist piling examples of data
versus curating that data which is sort
of an ongoing process of continuing to
go back and make sure that it's accurate
and up-to-date as you say versioned or
dated so that people know how
to use it it would you mind commenting
just a little bit about that distinction
of why that's so important about why the
yeah the accumulation versus the yes
well I think this is where there it is
we need to know what we know right now I
think this is extremely important and
this is also a as much hopeful as I am
in terms of their automated methods the
the automatic text mining can go through
all the literature and all the data sets
and find relations but they will not be
able to find what has been proven in I
does would be charity now it's really
important especially more and have
knowing what we know and it's a very
it's it's a very high goal but it's very
important in my opinion to be in order
to be able to progress further
there was a shepherd that dates from a
few years by John you and this that says
why most published research findings are
false and and that's probably an
exaggeration but they're certainly a lot
of hype in the literature and a lot of
of things that never get produced
once they're published once you know so
it's great but if have a real current
state of knowledge base we I think it's
very difficult for for us as a research
community to make progress in making new
relevant discoveries well I think in on
that comments this is a great place to
conclude our lecture from this morning
I'd like to thank Pascal g'day once
again for a very interesting lecture and
want to encourage you all to tune in
again next week on this same channel
same time
to here uh the next in our series again
we're very excited to be bringing this
to you please let others know or very
excited to have a rich audience and very
excited to be doing this again all the
videos will be shown on the bd2k
training coordinating Center website
here within moments after the lecture
it's a doctor good day to he's willing
and we'll make those available as well
yes once again one and enjoy your
weekends thank you thank you again
Pascal